[Music]
why don't we take
60 to 120 seconds just for you to
explain effective altruism your name is
often associated just so we have a
definition of terms and people have some
idea of the scope
and meaning of effective altruism since
you're considered
one of the creators or co-creators of
this entire movement if you wouldn't
mind just explaining that briefly and
that way people will have at least that
as a landmark as we go forward
effective altruism is a philosophy and a
community
that's about trying to figure out how
can we do as much good as possible with
the time and money we have
and then taking action on that basis so
putting those ideas into practice to i
actually try to make the world better as
effectively as possible whether that's
through our donations with our careers
with how we vote
with our consumption decisions just with
our entire lives
what have been some of the outcomes
of that
yeah so you know i've been promoting
these ideas along with others
for over 12 years now um we've raised
well over
or moved well over the billion dollars
to the most effective causes
so that means if we take just one
charity that we've raised money for
against malaria foundation
we've protected over 400 million
people mainly children
from malaria
and statistically that means we've saved
about 100 000 lives
or maybe a little more
uh which is you know the size of a small
town about the size of oxford
and that's just one charity there's
several more within global health and
development
i think
in terms of
uh other cause areas that we focused on
within animal health and welfare
hundreds of millions of
um hens are no longer in cages because
of corporate cage fee campaigns that
we've helped to fund
and then within the field of existential
risks there are
you know it's not as easy to say oh
we've done this concrete thing this
thing would have killed us all that we
avoided it but we have helped make ai
safety a much more mainstream field of
the search people taking the potential
benefits but also the risks from ai like
much more seriously than they were
we
are also like
have invested a lot in certain pandemic
preparedness measures again it's kind of
still early sages but some of the
technology there or things i think have
a really promising
potential to action at least
making sure that covert 19 is the last
pandemic we ever have
one of the many things i appreciate
about you and also
broadly speaking many people in the
effective altruism
community movement is
the taking of a systematic approach to
not just defining but questioning
assumptions and
quantitatively
looking at how you can do good not just
feel good
if that makes sense and it seems obvious
to anyone who's in the community but the
vast majority of
of
philanthropy
or
charity broadly speaking is done without
that type of
approach from what i can tell and
uh it's it's really worth
taking a closer look for those people
listening are there just a few urls
you'd like to mention for people who'd
like to dig into that and then we can
then we can move
into some of the
more current questions
for sure so if you're interested in how
to use your career to make the world
better then 80 000.org is you know a
terrific place to go i'm a co-founder of
that organization
gives in-depth career advice and
one-on-one
career coaching as well
if you're interested in donating some of
your money
then giving what we can.org encourages
people to take a giving pledge uh
typically 10 of one's income or more
it's a great way to live
if you're interested in donating to
effective charities then givewell.org is
the single best place for donating to
global health and development charities
that's givewell.org there's also the
effective altruism funds or ea funds
that allow you to donate within animal
welfare and existential risks
and
kind of promotion of these ideas as well
you